With three box office hits earning 1.17 billion dollars at the US box office...
...over the past three years, Kristen Stewart and Robert Pattinson...
...are Hollywood's highest-grossing romantic film couple.
The stars of the "Twilight" vampire films easily surpassed all other film twosomes...
...in the Forbes list that looked at the top ten grossing romantic films...
...of the last three years.
"There is something unique about these films..."
"...in the way that people have attached themselves to them,"...
...said Dorothy Pomerantz of Forbes.com.
"The movies are unconventional,..."
"...and you have the added element that the two people are a couple in real life," she added.
Stewart and Pattinson's offscreen romance...
...and breakup following Stewart's affair with Rupert Sanders,...
...the married director of her film "Snow White and the Huntsman,"
...fueled interest in the couple,...
...who reportedly reunited ahead of the release of the final film...
...in the popular "Twilight" series based on the novels by Stephenie Meyer.